la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue le président philippe bas pour
le groupe l'est républicain et pour deux
minutes
monsieur le premier ministre
dans l'épreuve par delà l'émotion
une fois de plus les français montrent
leur grandeur leur dignité leur force de
caractère
hier à versailles dans ce haut lieu de
l'histoire de france
la représentation nationale a exprimé
l'unité de la nation et le président de
la république a annoncé des décisions
parmi celles-ci beaucoup reprennent des
propositions récentes ou plus anciennes
que nous avions fait c'était nécessaire
le président de la république annoncé
qu'il prendrait également l'initiative
une révision de la constitution
notre collègue jacqueline gourault vous
a posé une question vous n'avez pas pu y
répondre de manière précise monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
en application de l'article 89 de la
constitution il vous appartient de faire
la proposition au président de la
république de révision de la
constitution
qu'est ce qui manque à notre
pour être efficace dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
que proposez vous de lui ajouter tu le
vends du ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président bah d'abord je veux saluer
comme vous la dignité et la force du
peuple français une nouvelle fois
j'avais l'occasion de le dire au lou
lire d'ailleurs dans une autre ambiance
à l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure
combien nous devons être attentifs en un
seul tour elle le rappelait à la
situation des victimes
nous nous allons vite dans nos analyses
et dans l'action c'est ce que nous
proposons sous l'autorité du président
de la république mais les français sont
choqués poser question expriment des
inquiétudes
il ya de la peur il ya aussi bien sûr de
la colère mais je veux penser aux
victimes à leurs familles à à leurs
proches
les corps n'ont pas été rendus les
obsèques n'ont pas eu lieu
il faut accompagner ses victimes je veux
le je veux le dire mais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous le dis du fond du coeur quand
les français nous regarde le président
larcher commence toujours toujours pas
ses mots cette séance en rappelant
qu'elle était divisée
pourrions-nous au moins surtout dans
cette séance particulièrement éclairé
les uns et les autres nous respecter
nous respecter
nous respecte je ne donne aucune leçon
je ne donne aucune leçon
certains d'entre vous s'exprime je vous
le dis calmement et je resterai tout à
fait calme je vous le dis je vais
jusqu'au bout et je réponds au président
bah si vous permettez encore si vous
permettez encore ou ceux qui ont voulu
m'interrompt je réponds monsieur le
président mais je le fais à ma manière
monsieur le président comme chef du
gouvernement et chacun sa place
vraiment il ya une réforme
constitutionnelle
elle a été proposée par le président de
la république et je comprends votre
impatience et nous trouverons je ne
doute pas le temps pour la préparer
c'est la mission que le président de la
république m'a confiées j'ai déjà
répondu à la sénatrice bourreau je ne
lui revient pas pour ce qui concerne le
prolongement de l'état d'urgence
deuxième idée c'est apporter une réponse
juridique efficace aux défis du
terrorisme
c'est aussi le président l'annoncé hier
élargir les possibilités de déchéance de
la nationalité le code civil permet de
déchoir de sa nationalité une personne
ayant acquis la nationalité française
ayant été condamné pour terrorisme sauf
si cela a pour effet de la rendre
apatride la révision constitutionnelle
proposée mais nous aurons l'occasion du
travail et permettra de déchoir
également de sa nationalité
une personne née française disposant de
la double nationalité est condamné pour
des faits de terrorisme pour atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
apporter une réponse juridique efficace
aux défis du terrorisme
c'est enfin créer un permis de retour
pour les france est convaincue d'avoir
participé à l'étranger à des activités
en lien avec le terrorisme soyons précis
comme ce qui a été fait par le royaume
uni d'ailleurs propositions ont été
faites ou si dans les rangs de
l'opposition j'imagine que ce qu'ils ont
fait ces propositions avaient réfléchi à
la question constitutionnelle
l'obtention de ce permis de retour
serait une étape obligatoire avant de
revenir sur le territoire national voilà
les raisons qui ont amené le chef de
l'état a proposé la modification de
notre constitution c'est-à-dire comme il
le souligne un de notre pacte collectif
pour permettre aux pouvoirs publics
d'agir conformément à l'état de droit
contre le terrorisme de guerre je
t'imagine il ya des propositions
notamment sur les fichages d'un certain
nombre des personnes le ministre de
l'intérieur avait l'occasion de répondre
tout à l'heure sur ce point à
l'assemblée nationale je les fais aussi
en répandant à monsieur wauquiez qui
nécessiteront peut-être là aussi
incontestablement si nous voulons être
conforme à notre droit constitutionnel
des réformes mettant les choses sur la
table avait fait des propositions
nous avons engagé beaucoup de réformes
si nous voulons à l'avancé ensemble être
digne de cette attitude du peuple
français
c'est comme ça que nous avons serait ni
par les invectives n'est par
l'interruption mais droit debout mais
avec la volonté de répondre aux français
et de manière efficace
monsieur le président monsieur le
président bat pour 40 secondes droit
debout monsieur le premier ministre je
veux vous dire que la constitution et le
pacte fondamental qui unit tous les
français et qu'il n'en ait pas de plus
élevé on ne doit la réviser que pour des
raisons impérieuses
les explications que vous venez de nous
donner exige davantage encore de
précision si vous voulez pouvoir
convaincre la commission des lois du
sénat et le sénat tout entier qui sont
naturellement disponible pour y
travailler avec vous mais je rappelle
que notre constitution a permis de
lutter contre les attentats de l'oas de
faire face aux troubles en nouvelle
calédonie de répondre à l'épreuve des
émeutes dans les banlieues et je ne vois
pas qu'aujourd'hui elle vous empêche de
mettre en oeuvre l'état d'urgence merci
dont la parole
le premier ministe brièvement s'il vous
plaît pour permettre à tout le monde
oui mais être télévisé bien sûr mais un
mot l'état d'urgence douze jours
prolongée par une loi
trois mois une loi qui évidemment avait
été imaginé dans des circonstances en
1955 qui a été appliquée dans d'autres
conditions
rien n'est comparable ni la nouvelle
calédonie ni cette loi qui a été ou
cette situation cette décision par le
premier ministre de villepin qui a été
mise en oeuvre à la fin du processus des
émeutes urbaines en ile de france en
là il s'agit d'imaginer comment au bout
de ces trois mois nous pouvons
bénéficier intégré dans le droit
fondamental dans la constitution dans la
loi fondamentale
un certain nombre d'éléments c'est
l'engagement du président la république
et mon engagement c'est que nous
puissions ensemble ils travaillent et
c'est le début d'un processus
monsieur bah c'est pas aujourd'hui que
je peux vous répondre sur tous les
points précisément mais je ne doute pas
qu ensemble nous avancerons et
sincèrement merci